- [Kelly] So, you are so
great in the new movie.
I love the movie. I
was telling him I love,
literally my kids loved it so much.
They sent it to us earlier,
and we watched it like three times.
- [Marlon] Good. Thank you.
- My kids loved it.
And I thought, I kept thinking maybe
they might be scared at certain things,
like the the red thing, like pumpkin.
I was like, "Maybe..." But nope.
So when did you know you wanted to act?
'Cause you're so young.
- Um, I've always had
like a big personality
ever since I was younger.
Like everywhere I would go,
I would just make
conversation with people.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I did impersonations
as well when I was younger.
I would impersonate Wendy Williams
when her first show came out.
[Marlon Laughs]
- I would walk around
in my mom's blonde wig
and I would impersonate her.
And I was also into a lot of movies
that had a lot of drama
to them and suspense.
So I guess a mixture
of all those things kind
of drew me to acting.
- [Kelly] I love that.
It was a really, really great film.
I loved y'all's chemistry.
-[Marlon] Thank you
- [Kelly] it was, it was so fun.
- It was funny cuz I thought she knew,
I knew her work from 'Stranger Things'
and I just loved, you know, it was
like her sassy little attitude.
She always had something
to say and I thought
for a father to have to deal
with that big personality
and understand that, it's not wrong.
She's just expressing
herself and you have to
understand this youth in this culture.
And I thought she knew my work.
This girl ain't no none of my work.
- I did know your work!
- I said how'd you not see 'White Chicks'
What is wrong with you child?
[Kelly Laughs]
[Audience Claps]
- I watched 'Scary Movie'.